dijon ne l'est absolument pas assez
alors que nous avons la chance d'avoir
une ville compacte assez plate donc qui
devrait pouvoir favoriser beaucoup plus
les vélos parce que nous observons de la
part du vélo localement malgré toutes
les attentions depuis dix ans la part du
vélo
donc il faut vraiment se poser des
questions sur les coûts on a construit
près de 350 km de pistes cyclables dont
calais vélo compatibles nous sommes la
quatrième ville française
c'est vrai qu'on a un peu reculé mais
d'une compétition c'est bien on est la
quatrième ville française avec 3 5% de
parts du vélo direction effectivement
nous revendiquons nous avons écrit
pendant la période de confinement au
maire de dijon qui n'a pas pris en
compte nos demandes c'est à dire de
profiter de cette période là pour
expérimenter de nouvelles portions de
piste cyclable sécurisée
donc c'est à dire en site propre qui ne
viennent pas soit sur trottoir soit avec
les voitures en site propre pour
améliorer et pour inciter au moment
d'aider confinement les gens à reprendre
le ville l'objectif c'est d'atteindre 12
% de parts du et donc on va continuer on
va améliorer on va continuer de
construire des pistes cyclables
oui elle est des lots compatit bien
évidemment